la séance est ouverte l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions au gouvernement
la parole est à madame alors blain merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre dix jours
voici dix jours qu'un nouvel acte de
barbarie a frappé la france pendant 24
heures nous aurions pu penser qu'il y
avait enfin une prise de conscience
générale
notre pays osons dire oui et la cible
d'un islam politique qui nous ronge de
l'intérieur
quand on lit qu'un sondage dévoile que
27% des sondés veulent que la charia
s'impose aux lois de la république
que doit-on en déduire qu'en plus de la
moitié des enseignants souhaitent
s'autocensurer pour éviter les incidents
que doit-on en penser
quand nos prisons regorgent de
prisonniers de nationalités étrangères
susceptibles de se radicaliser que
fait-on allons nous dire enfin
catégoriquement que l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'union européenne doit
être exclue et que la question de sa
sortie de l'otan doit être évoquée
allons nous continuer à subir les
pressions extérieures à les laisser nous
dicter notre conduite
ces forces étrangères insultent notre
souveraineté
nos valeurs nos libertés nos
institutions et même notre président de
la république
l'islam politique nous fait du chantage
économique des chantages aux migrants
allons-nous faire preuve d'autorité
où allons-nous encore cédé finalement
monsieur le premier ministre
quand allez vous enfin défendre nos
valeurs françaises
notre civilisation judéo-chrétienne qu
allez vous enfin déclarer la guerre à
l'islam politique
merci même le d'éviter la parole est à
monsieur franck riester ministre délégué
chargé du commerce extérieur et de
l'attractivité
merci merci
attendez monsieur le ministre mesdames
messieurs je vous signale que le
gouvernement désigne librement quel est
sont membres qui répond aux questions
que vous gardez vos protestations pour
vous la parole à monsieur ries esther et
à faire prendre merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
madame la députée blain phase soit aux
déclarations de n
face aux attaques face au boycott de ces
produits la france est décidée à
défendre ses valeurs
jean yves le drian est actuellement à
brazzaville pour célébrer l'anniversaire
à quelques jours près il ya 80 ans du
manifeste lancé par le général de gaulle
à ses heures sombres dans ces heures
sombres déjà la france n'était pas seule
madame la députée toute l'europe
toute l'europe est unie pour dénoncer
les propos haineux du président r doan
qui a très clairement attaqué non
seulement bien évidemment le priant de
la république
mais la france ne soyons dupe de rien
c'est parce que la france porte haut ses
valeurs et déterminés à défendre
justement l'islam radical qui minent une
partie de sa population aujourd'hui que
la france est attaquée ainsi mais ce
n'est pas une question franco turque
c'est une question justement de l'europe
face aux dérives nationale aux
islamistes du président r doan et l'afld
l'europe et la france ont uni pour
défendre leurs intérêts et pour défendre
leurs valeurs
merci monsieur
la parole est à monsieur fabien roussel
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre la france
est insulté le président de la
république est attaquée personnellement
par le président erdogan suite à
l'ignoble crime contre samuel pâtit
suite à l'attentât islamiste perpétré
sur notre sol la france insulter la
france stigmatiser la france provoque et
c'est extrêmement grave
nous ne l'accepterons jamais au nom des
valeurs héritées de la révolution
française
au nom de notre république laïque au nom
du sang versé ici dans notre pays pour
que nous puissions vivre libres et égaux
en droits je ne doute pas un instant de
l'union de toute la nation de tous les
citoyens quelles que soient leurs
opinions politiques
quelle que soit leur confession
religieuse de nombreux pays du monde
arabe et musulman ont d'ailleurs exprimé
leur solidarité envers la france salue
on les met une telle provocation de la
part de dirigeants de monarque qui
affichent leur soutien des organisations
djihadistes à des réseaux islamistes et
d'une extrême gravité
ce sont eux qui théorisent avec les
conservateurs américains et d'autres y
compris en france
un choc des civilisations est une guerre
des religions
soyons unis pour refuser cette escalade
guerrière pour éviter la surenchère être
unis mais être ferme aussi résister à
cette spirale doit aussi nous invite à
revoir peut-être nos relations nouées
avec ces pays ces dernières années
commerce des armes convention fiscale
avantageuse pour le qatar participation
à l'otan avec la turquie
quand dans le même temps air dogan
pourchassent les kurdes menacent la
grèce chypre et livrent une guerre
meurtrière en a remis
monsieur le premier ministre cette
meilleure réponse que nous devons
inventer dans ce combat commun contre
l'obscurantisme contre l'islamisme dont
les musulmans sont aussi les victimes
résolument dans le cas de la ministre
déléguée chargée du commerce extérieur
et de l'attractivité monsieur merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
roussel unis et ferme
vous avez raison c'est la ligne de la
france unie au niveau des différentes
formations politiques de notre pays à
part quelques exceptions choquant prêt
et je tiens à saluer cette unité des
forces politiques de notre pays
unité de l'europe je le disais à
l'instant où la quasi unanimité des pays
de l'union européenne ont dénoncé avec
force les propos de monsieur erdogan
mobilisation aussi et soutien de
nombreux pays allié de la france
notamment au sein du monde musulman
oui nous devons être unis face à ces
propos haineux face à ces dérives
nationale aux islamistes
la france a pris la décision face à
l'attitude de monsieur erdogan de
rappeler son ambassadeur pour
consultations
cela fait suite d'abord à l'absence
choquant de toute condamnation de
l'attentât de condé sainte livière par
le président erdogan
cela fait suite aussi à cette campagne
véhiculées par la presse turque et les
réseaux sociaux turque contre la france
contre ses intérêts et contre le
président de la république et enfin le
discours du président r doan attaquant
directement le président de la
république et la france nous avons donc
rappeler notre ambassadeur
nous avons pris la décision d'être unis
avec les européens et l'or et lors du
proche et lors du prochain conseil
européen nous aurons des discussions
avec nos partenaires européens pour voir
la réaction forte qu'il faudra avoir
vis-à-vis de la turquie pour défendre
non seulement nos intérêts mais aussi
défendre nos valeurs
pas risque parce qu'il s'agit en
l'espèce aussi de la défense des valeurs
françaises et européennes merci monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à mme adama mais via la
graphie merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre franck riester ministre délégué
auprès de 1002 l'europe les affaires
étrangères monsieur le ministre la
france fidèle à ses valeurs de partage
et d'ouverture a toujours créé des
passerelles entre les mondes par sa
diplomatie culturelle
elle construit des ponts entre les
civilisations à l'instar de l'institut
du monde arabe de paris ou du musée du
louvre d'abu dhabi elle entretient des
relations anciennes et étroite avec
l'ensemble du monde musulman sur la
scène internationale elle prend
régulièrement la défense des minorités
persécutées notamment musulmanes au
moyen-orient est le côté des peuples
comme au liban ou en irak
dernièrement ses relations fraternelles
sont aujourd'hui attaquée par ceux qui
propagent des messages de haine ceux qui
insultent notre président et appellent
au boycott des produits français sont
porteurs d'un projet qui n'a rien à voir
avec la défense du culte musulman
pratiquer librement en france les
français ceux de l'hexagone d'outre-mer
ou de l'étranger attendent un message
celui de dire qu'il existe sur notre sol
un islam radical dont l'objectif
politique est de diviser notre société
ait refusé nos lois
lors de l'hommage national à samuel
pâtit le président de la république a
prononcé des mots clairs et acceptable
par tous je le cite
nous ne renoncerons pas aux caricatures
eaux descend
nous cultiverons la tolérance nous
continuerons ce combat pour la liberté
chacun devrait le comprendre ici comme
ailleurs dans ses propos il n'y a ni
offensif ni volonté de blesser ou de
stigmatiser il y à l'affirmation de ce
que nous sommes collectivement tant que
nation en tant que peuple en tant
qu'homme et de femmes libres la
république protège l'exercice des cultes
mais jamais la foi ne doit être au
dessus de la loi monsieur le ministre
quelles actions la diplomatie française
compte elle entreprend donc continuer de
porter notre message d'amitié de par le
monde
tout en affirmant que jamais notre pays
ne revenir à son idéal
liberté d'égalité de fraternité et de
laïcité je vous remercie
merci va débuter la parole à monsieur
franck riester ministre délégué chargé
du commerce extérieur et de
l'attractivité monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée la graphie la france comme je
les dis à l'instant est déterminé à
défendre ses valeurs et à lutter contre
l'islam radical
nous sommes déterminés aussi à expliquer
quelle est la politique justement de la
france à tous nos partenaires du monde
musulman particulièrement c'est la
raison pour laquelle nos ambassadeurs
ont pris les contacts qu'il était
nécessaire de prendre pour expliquer ce
qu'était la politique de la france pour
veiller en plein contact avec les
entreprises qui sont victimes du boycott
de leurs produits
même si ces boycotts je dois le dire ici
sont très circonscrit et d'expliquer à
quel point la politique de la france est
de défendre ses valeurs celles valeurs
de liberté de liberté d'expression de
lutter contre l'islam radical
mais en aucun cas d'attaqué l'islam bien
évidemment les musulmans sont libres de
pratiquer leur culte en france les
musulmans sont des citoyens à part
entière
évidemment et donc nous rappelons face à
ces calomnies face à cette manipulation
de l'information notamment des réseaux
turcs notamment d'un certain nombre de
réseaux sociaux qui peuvent manipuler
certaines personnes qui en toute bonne
foi pense éventuellement que la france
aurait des attaques contre l'islam
pour bien réaffirmer qu'elle est la
politique de la france une politique qui
est la politique d'une république
ouverte et libre où tous les cultes
peuvent être pratiqués librement et où
chaque entreprise a le droit à
l'international de pouvoir vendre ses
produits en toute liberté
c'est ça les démarches que
son qui sont mobilisés aujourd'hui par
le réseau diplomatique de la france pour
faire cesser ces pratiques de boycott de
ces produits merci merci monsieur le
ministre avant de lui donner la parole
je suis heureux de souhaiter la
bienvenue à monsieur julien ravier
devenu député de la première
circonscription des bouches du rhône le
8 octobre dernier en remplacement de
madame valérie boyer monsieur ravier
bienvenus vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre le
président de la république a décrété de
façon discrétionnaire
un couvre-feu dans 54 départements avec
des conséquences dramatiques pour les
secteurs de la restauration de
l'hôtellerie et encore du spectacle
notamment dans la ville de marseille que
je représente aujourd'hui la tenue de
deux conseils de défense nous laisse
penser à l'application de mesures encore
plus restrictive force est de constater
qu'il s'agit là d'une énième preuve de
votre échec cinglant dans la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire
déjà en début de crise vous nous
expliquer que les masques et les tests
massif était inutile parce que vous en
avez la parole quant au président de la
république
il nous expliquait le 14 juillet dernier
je le cite en cas de seconde vague
nous serons prêts en réalité en six mois
vous avez été incapables de nous
préparer à cette deuxième vague car
protégé les français
ce n'est pas seulement restreindre leur
liberté de travailler ou de se divertir
mais c'est apporter une réponse
sanitaire à la hauteur des enjeux
même si nous ne contestons pas l'usure
d'urgence instauré un couvre-feu ou 1re
confinement partiel tout ceci symbolise
l'échec total du test et racé isolé
l'échec de votre décompte il n'aura t
l'échec du renforcement du système
hospitalier
l'échec de l'ouverture qui dirait une
animation supplémentaire
l'échec du rgo du recrutement et de la
formation de personnels de santé
en définitive si l'échec cuisant de la
stratégie du président de la république
et du gouvernement
alors monsieur le premier ministre je
vous le demande
qu'avez vous fait pour préparer notre
système de santé à cette deuxième vague
quelles nouvelles mesures d'urgence
allez vous prendre pour attraper enfin
le temps perdu
allez vous enfin enfin inscrire le coc
vide comme maladie à déclaration
obligatoire mais aussi et surtout celle
où allez-vous suivre les propositions du
professeur jugé incomplet en ouvrant des
hôpitaux éphémère des lits de
réanimation en formant des aides
soignantes et les infirmières sur
quelques tâches nouvelles cibles sur le
papier mais bon on se calme on se calme
et on laisse monsieur gabriel a tall
secrétaire d'état auprès du président
porte-parole du gouvernement le soin de
répondre à monsieur ravier
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vous écoutez c'est à
se demander si vous ne considérez pas
que c'est ce gouvernement qui a qui est
responsable de la diffusion d'un virus
sur la planète entière dans le monde
entier qui concerne aujourd'hui toute
l'europe
à vous écouter on a l'impression que
vous ne voyez pas ce qui se passe dans
le monde que vous ne voyez pas ce qui se
passe dans le reste de l'europe
c'est-à-dire une seconde vague qui
touche tous les pays européens c'est à
dire un virus qui réapparaît en france
comme une réapparu en italie comme une
vraie apparaît en allemagne comme il
réapparaît chez nos voisins je vous le
dit monsieur le député propos d'abord
sont irresponsables
oui il est irresponsable dans le moment
que nous vivons d'attiser les craintes
d' attiser les but d'attiser les
inquiétudes vous parler de la situation
des restaurateurs ou pas et la situation
de nos entreprises
évidemment que nous avons à coeur de
leur répondre c'est ce que nous faisons
depuis le début de cette crise avec
toutes les mesures qui ont été mises en
place et je vous invite à trouver un
pays en europe qui a pris les mesures
que nous avons prises pour les protéger
vous parlez de l'épidémie évidemment
nous avons à coeur de protéger les
français depuis le début de cette crise
notre seule boussole a été la protection
de la santé des français
la protection de la sécurité des
français et nous allons continuer à le
faire les responsables je disais parce
que vous feignez d'ignorer la situation
que connaît le monde ils responsables
aussi parce qu'une nouvelle fois vous
êtes dans l'incapacité la plus absolue
de proposer des mesures alternatives
vous n'avez aucun plots vous n'avez
aucune idée si vous étiez aux affaires
qu'est ce que ce serait vous le ferez
rien vous seriez en train de regarder la
situation se dérouler
nous nous prenons nos responsabilités
nous allons continuer à prendre leurs
responsabilités et nous n'assumons de le
faire nous sommes à part au savoir des
leçons quand vous venez de le faire
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame sabine qu'il est à elle seule
vous avez la parole
merci merci monsieur le président le
gouvernement d'ankara centre de se
laisser emporter sur le champ de la
cause de l'outrance et de loutres âge
loutrons c'est celle qui s'exprime par
la voix de son président qui ne pouvent
plus de mots assez forts pour tenter de
se racheter un crédit intérieur aux
dépens de l'europe
les multiples rotomontades aux qualités
de livres ne doivent pas cacher son
ambition celle d'une expansion
territoriale et d' influence dont nous
ne devons pas être dupe loutre hcc lui
qui insultent notre pays qui lui ne
s'est jamais départi de son idéal celui
des nations unies autour de sa
citoyenneté et qui s'exprime dans un
cadre laïc
monsieur le ministre il n'est pas besoin
de souligner les nombreuses
interventions le montre la consternation
de la représentation nationale
devant un tel comportement qui trahit le
message de liberté de notre république
les propos du président turc sont
inacceptables et attise les
révendications des minorités activistes
nous saluons le soutien de nombreux
états européens qui n'accepte pas cette
mise en cause c'est cette fuite en avant
les conséquences de tels agissements
pourrait être néfaste et nous devons
désormais aussi agir pour trouver une
lucie qui ne soit pas dans la surenchère
la france 3 enlevés pour une réaction
européenne commune l'union européenne
doit affirmer sur la scène
internationale ces principes
démocratiques et la liberté de
conscience
le conseil européen avait déjà appelé à
une volonté turque d'apaisement pour
lancer un programme politique
constructif
soulignons qu'à défaut la turquie sera
encore plus isolé sur la scène
internationale
monsieur le ministre quelle
signification a vraiment le rappel de
notre ambassadeur en turquie
et quelles réponses concrètes la france
et l'union européenne peuvent elles
apporter à ces manoeuvres inacceptable
je vous remercie
merci
japonais la parole est à monsieur franck
riester ministre délégué chargé du
commerce extérieur et de l'attractivité
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
pied vous l'avez dit 7
nous oui je peux m'adresser à tous toute
l'assemblée
monsieur le député cette séquence turc
est une séquence qui fait suite à de
nombreux autres séquences et qui
s'inscrit dans une démarche de la
turquie qui est une démarche ne nous y
trompons pas qui vise à étendre le
rayonnement et l'emprise de la turquie
sur un certain nombre de régions
voisines
cela fait suite cela fait suite aux
caisses qui monsieur le député vous ne
pouvez me laisser parler peut-être ça
fait suite
cela fait suite au viol viol de
l'embargo libyen depuis des mois en
libye
cela fait suite aux actions de la
turquie dans le haut-karabagh avec le
soutien d'envoi de mercenaires vers la
vers le haut karabagh pour soutenir
l'azerbaïdjan
ça fait suite à la stratégie turque dans
la méditerranée orientale pour inciter à
des explorations gazières dans les eaux
territoriales ou d'économie exclusive
chypriote grecque
cela fait suite à l'absence de
condamnation par la turquie de ce qui
s'est passé avec l'attentât compte des
de conflans sainte honorine
cela fait suite à cette déclaration
scandaleuse du président r doan face au
président de la république française
bref c'est un ensemble d'actions que la
france dénonce avec force mais elle
n'est pas la seule à le dénoncer toute
l'europe dénonce ces comportements de
cieux air doan et nous devrons avoir
nos répliques européenne lors du
prochain conseil européen de décembre
merci monsieur nous la parole est un
monsieur avec chic lors bière monsieur
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
vous vous êtes permis ces derniers jours
d'être particulièrement insultants
envers beaucoup de personnes et
d'institutions en utilisant des
arguments outrancier dans votre charge
vous n'êtes plus crédible d'endosser le
costume du défenseur de l'école publique
et laïque
mais je dois le dire ce costume ne vous
voit pas car c'est vous qui avez fait du
mal à l'école publique ces 15 dernières
années
c'est vous qui avez supprimé 80 mille
postes d'enseignants entre 2007 et 2012
lorsque vous étiez dgesco
c'est vous qui avez encouragé les écoles
privées comme espérance banlieue une
école privée hors contrat dans le
fondateur selon la presse propose qu'une
messe soit dite au début de chaque
conseil d'administration et vous aviez
dit à ce sujet sur les réseaux ce que
fait espérance banlieue fait partie des
initiatives que nous devons prendre ces
votre louable anker adopté en 2019 qui a
accordé 100 millions d'euros à
l'enseignement privé qui à 90%
confessionnelles et qui fait concurrence
à l'école publique et laïque
c'est vous qui en 2007 comme directeur
adjoint du cabinet du ministre avait
imposé aux recteurs morvan de l'académie
de lyon
l'installation d'une école privée dont
on sait aujourd'hui que sa filiale
suédoise avait des liens avec al qaïda
la liste est longue de tous les mauvais
coups contre l'école laïque et vous
voilà maintenant que vous ciblez
l'université française qui deviendrait
le lieu d'un développement dangereux du
théorie slam aux gauchistes que vous ne
savez pas définir la conférence des
présidents d'université vous a répondu
avec clarté jala site non les
universités ne sont pas des lieux où se
développe une idéologie qui mène au pire
non les universités ne saurait être tenu
pour complice du terroriste mais vous
avez gagné aujourd'hui une alliée de
choix
madame marion maréchal-le pen s'est
réjouie de vos propos allah dit le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
reprend notre analyse du danger des
idéologies intersectionnelle alors
monsieur le ministre il est
en finir avec vos mauvais coup contre
l'école laïque et public et il est temps
que vous cessiez de parler comme
l'extrême droite
merci la parole la parole est à monsieur
jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
les sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
alexis corbière s'est pas entendu une
question dans votre intervention mais je
vais quand même essayer d'y répondre
d'abord ça ne m'étonne pas que ce soit
vous qui prenez la parole pour et les
filles parce que d'une certaine façon
vous êtes et les filles à visage
républicain et je ne doute pas de vos
convictions républicaines puisque je
vous ai lu j'ai lu votre livre sur les
jacobins par exemple monsieur mélenchon
ne m'a pas lui sinon elle ne dirai pas
ce qu'il a dit hier sur une radio et des
insultes vers des fonctionnaires pas
vers le ministre ce qui est scandaleux
d'après le républicain et donc je vais
vous répondre parce que désormais pour
vous être laïc et républicain c'est être
d'extrême droite parce que pour vous il
faudrait laisser à l'extrême droite
parfois des discours sur ces sujets non
in medio stat virtus je voulais déjà dit
dans un débat au milieu se tient le
courage c'est à dire dans les positions
déquilibre pas dans les positions
extrémistes que vous prenez pas dans les
manifestations avec le ccf auxquels vous
étiez non pas vous mais une partie de
l'ailé fille
dans les propos de monsieur mélenchon
qui quand il parle de communautarisme
parle du crif et n'en vois pas d'autre
en france pas non plus dans la
dénonciation pas dans les phrases comme
celle qui consiste à dire que le seul
séparatisme serait celui des riches
alors votre aveuglement sur la laïcité
votre aveuglement sur le séparatisme
vous n'avez plus le droit de la voir
après ce qui s'est passé après cet
assassinat
vous n'avez pas le droit d'avoir des
complicité intellectuelle avec cela vous
ne devez pas tourner le dos vous ne
devez pas tourner le dos aux idéaux de
la révolution française
normalement c'est ce qui nous réunit
tous donc si quand on est républicain
on est d'extrême droite ce que je dis
c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous avez un
problème avec la république
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur meyer habib et à lui seul
avait là bas merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
jean castex j'aimerais beaucoup vous
écouter sur cette question jusqu'à quand
allons-nous tolérer les provocations du
président de gan
ça a été rapide n'a pas eu un seul mot
de condamnation après l'assassinât
atroce de samuel pâtit ce professeur
décapité par un islamiste samedi erdogan
suggère au président de la république de
passer un examen de santé mentale
du jamais vu dimanche le leader
islamiste récidive
lundi ils appellent à boycotter la
france si ce n'est pas une déclaration
de guerre ça y ressemble fortement
quand on attaque le chef de l'état on
attaque la nation députés notamment des
français turquie que voudrait lui
témoigner le soutien total de notre
groupe nous sommes tous unis derrière le
président de la république un dogue
année par un de l'islam politique en
france
il orchestre une campagne de haine et de
calomnies alors que l'islamisme défigure
la france il ose comparer le sort des
musulmans d'europe à celui des juifs
avant guerre
comme ces islamo gauchistes qui
défilaient à paris avec l'étoile jaune
sur des jeunes enfants
en france les musulmans sont des
citoyens à part entière
la majorité respecte les lois de la
république y compris les turcs qui
résident dans notre pays
erdogan s'est courage à géométrie
variable ils courbent l'échiné devant
poutine pas et moss pour les ouïghours
persécutés en firent pourtant
turcophones et musulmans
le sultan pyromane ne semble comprendre
que les rapports de force
monsieur le premier ministre nous payons
nos faiblesses que je né sais c'est
dénoncer chantage migratoire
islamisation de la basilique
sainte-sophie véritable gifle chrétiens
d'orient violation de souveraineté
grecque et chypre en méditerranée
financement des frères musulmans
massacre des kurdes expansionnisme néo
ottoman syrie en libye dans le
haut-karabagh arménien soutien actif aux
ont ramassé aux mouvances palestiniennes
la liste est longue et ne cesse de
s'allonger stop ça suffit jean
christophe lagarde vous a écrit du 10
septembre pour demander un débat urgent
sur cette question monsieur le premier
ministre
quelle mesure quelles mesures de
rétorsion comprendre la france face aux
agressions d'erdogan mai
si monsieur député la balle est à
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député a bible je ne suis
pas certain qu'il faille répondent par
l'insulté et la provocation à la
médiocrité à la vulgarité et à la
provocation
ce qui est certain c'est que le
président de la république dans son
discours aux mureaux a touché juste
il a touché juste parce qu'il a
justement dénoncée et c'est ce qui sera
présenté à l'assemblée nationale en
janvier prochain par le texte que
j'aurai l'honneur de porter à la demande
du premier ministre il a dénoncé les
ingérences étrangères sur notre sol
quelle belle plus grande preuve que
celle de la réaction du dirigeant de la
turquie que nous ne confondons pas avec
le peuple turc quelqu'un gros peuple etc
est un grand pays vous dire que lorsque
des dirigeants étrangers se croient des
droits sur des citoyens français
cela nous choque de dire que nous ne
distinguons pas à nous en france les
citoyens par leur couleur de peau par
leur lieu de naissance par leur origine
par leur confession
ils sont tous français et ensuite ils
ont une confession et ensuite ils ont
éventuellement une origine si la
revendique
et nous disons que personne ne peut
faire en france la politique intérieure
à la place des français
je crois que ce rappel est nécessaire au
président erdogan
nous considérons en effet que les liens
incestueux que certaines puissances
étrangères ont sur le sol national en
utilisant une religion pour pouvoir
faire du soft ou du hard power et c'est
quelque chose dont nous devons terminer
et mettre un point final le président
l'a fait sur les imams détaché le
président le fait sur le financement des
lieux de culte
le présent le fait en prenant des
mesures courageuses que nous vous
présenterons dans le texte
effectivement dit séparatisme et nous
serons très fiers monsieur députés que
vous puissiez voter ce texte avec nous
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
un monsieur boris vallot merci monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre hier étaient convoqués en
urgence
un puis deux conseil de défense les
chefs de partis de groupes
parlementaires les partenaires sociaux
ont été convoqués leur tour de façon
expresse pour cet après midi des
ministres ont quitté précipitamment le
banc pour rejoindre matignon et le
ministre de la santé a annulé l'audition
devant la commission denquête ce qu'il
devait assurer cet après midi le
sentiment d'un vent de panique est
saisissant le 14 juillet dernier le
président de la république affirmait que
nous étions prêts à affronter une
seconde vague vous même le 27 août vous
déclariez je vous cite que face à la
pandémie il n'y a pas de quoi s'affoler
et le 22 octobre dernier c'est le
ministre de la santé qui avançait à
l'appui du couvre feu que sans mesures
nouvelles là où c'est nécessaire pour
freiner l'épidémie
il y aurait dans les 15 jours jusqu'à
cinquante mille malades diagnostiqués
quotidiennement nous avons atteint ce
seuil quatre jours après cette
déclaration je crains que vous n'ayez
d'une certaine manière participé d'un
relâchement dans notre combat contre ce
virus
aujourd'hui c'est la larme le conseil
scientifique l'audit plusieurs plusieurs
semaines l'incidence est hors de
contrôle l'hôpital se prépare au pire et
des mesures difficiles doivent être
prises monsieur le premier ministre
les français sont inquiets de l'épidémie
mais ils le sont aussi des
tergiversations dans la gestion de la
crise depuis le début de la crise les
socialistes et apparentés en région
responsabilités ont formulé des
propositions chaque fois qu'ils
pouvaient en vain je vous la corde et
nous avons toujours soutenu le strict
respect des dispositions sanitaires que
vous aviez décidé mais nous avons besoin
de clarté nous avons besoin de
transparence nous avons besoin de
diligence monsieur le premier ministre
il devient difficile de croire que vous
avez tiré toutes les conséquences de la
première vague notamment dans la
préparation d'hôpital difficile de ne
pas considérer que vous avez manqué
d'anticipation et on définitive
peut-être échoué dans le déconfinement
dont vous aviez la charge
les français ont besoin de comprendre
pour avoir confiance
vous savez les efforts qu'ils ont
accompli monsieur le premier ministre
pouvez-vous nous rassurer avez-vous
encore le contrôle pouvez vous nous dire
quelle est la stratégie du gouvernement
et si nous allons vers un nouveau
confinement merci monsieur début dé la
parole et à madame brigitte bourguignon
ministre délégué chargé de l'autonomie
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député boris vallot la situation
sanitaire et nous en convenons tous n'a
cessé de se dégrader en france comme
dans les autres pays
d'ailleurs les chiffres sont
malheureusement implacable la deuxième
vague est là et elle est très très forte
plusieurs dispositifs ont été déployés
notamment l'état d'urgence sanitaire
sont l'ensemble du territoire national
et le couvre-feu employés dans désormais
plus de 54 départements dont un
d'outre-mer ces mesures sont difficiles
absolument nécessaire par contre pour
protéger les français face à cette vague
qui met en danger non seulement les plus
vulnérables mais également notre système
de santé et son personnel qui depuis le
mois de mars bat sans relâche et que
nous pouvons encore salué contre ce
virus depuis le début de la crise le
gouvernement a initié une démarche de
transparence vis-à-vis des français et
de l'ensemble des forces politiques ce
que vous demandez c'est pourquoi les
collectivités concernées sont conviés à
des points réguliers avec les préfets
les ars ces concertations se poursuivent
également au niveau national avec les
organisations politiques de notre pays
même transparence aussi avant le
déploiement des couvre-feux dans les
métropoles
ce couvre-feu monsieur le député n'est
pas pris de gaieté de coeur et vous le
savez mais c'est à ce stade un des
outils mise en oeuvre pour freiner la
circulation
réponse efficace local adapté depuis
plusieurs mois notre stratégie face au
virus a été graduelle territorialisées
nous avons choisi d'agir ville par ville
plutôt que favoriser d interdiction
généralisée
toutes ces mesures ont porté leurs
fruits la rentrée scolaire a pu se
passer et tout le monde le salue
malheureusement comme partout en europe
la circulation du virus s'accélère en
france sur l'ensemble du territoire et
nous en prenons acte vous le savez comme
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
nous continuerons d'âge
lire pour prévenir limiter autant que
possible les différents foyers de
contamination
personne n'a la solution vous le savez
et nous agissons
c'est le sens de notre action qui
évoluent en parfaite transparence et en
conséquence je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur jean baptiste moreau merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture
en mai dernier la commission européenne
présentait sa stratégie femmes to fork
afin de traduire la volonté d'une
transition du modèle agricole européen
vers un modèle plus durable et plus
respectueux de l'environnement
cette trajectoire a été confortée par
l'accord trouvé la semaine dernière
entre les ministres de l'agriculture
européens dans le cadre des négociations
de la prochaine politique agricole
commune
soyons honnêtes les discussions
n'étaient pas très bien parti en 2018
mais là on ne peut que se réjouir du
maintien du budget de 380 7 milliards
d'euros pour les sept prochaines années
ce budget est à la fois vital pour nos
agriculteurs et pour la préservation de
notre souveraineté agricoles et
alimentaires françaises et européennes
l'autre attente concernait le vent
verdissement de la pac je tenais à celui
votre détermination monsieur le ministre
en faveur d'une harmonisation des normes
européennes en matière environnementale
au sein d'un marché commun il faut que
nos agriculteurs puissent répondre des
mêmes règles
je tenais à celui aussi la mise en place
d et costumes qui permettront de
rémunérer les agriculteurs pour les
services environnementaux qu'ils rendent
en rampant dans en répondant en même
temps aux attentes de nos concitoyens
cette rémunération les encouragera à
s'engager vers des pratiques
agroécologiques et chaque état devra y
consacrer 20% des paiements directs de
l'union européenne 1 minimes 1 certains
pays de l'ex europe de l'est voulait
soit rendre optionnelle c'est et
costumes soient y consacrer une part
moindre de leurs budgets
votre volonté monsieur le ministre a
permis de les convaincre et nous devons
nous en réjouir et vous féliciter par
ailleurs cet accord est une bonne
réponse aux difficultés rencontrées par
l'application de la loi et galim
notamment ce qui concerne la
structuration des filières en prévoyant
la capacité d aider au regroupement des
organisations de producteurs à l'aide
des programmes sectoriels et
opérationnel monsieur le ministre la
question est simple comment cet accord
va se traduire concrètement dans la vie
de nos agriculteurs
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député jean baptiste
moreau oui cette nouvelle politique
agricole commune est un succès oui c'est
un succès parce que d'abord elle permet
de garantir le revenu de nos
agriculteurs vous l'avez dit monsieur le
député c'est tout le travail fait par le
président de la république pour
augmenter significativement le budget de
la politique agricole commune au niveau
européen et c'est ce que nous avons
obtenu
et puis oui cette politique agricole
commune c'est un succès parce qu'elle va
nous donner plus de souveraineté dans
nos actions au quotidien
je pense à toute cette énergie que nous
déployons sur le problème protéines sur
la question viticole et puis surtout
cette politique agricole commune est un
succès parce que l accompagne la
transition agro environnementales sans
jamais ne tomber dans la naïveté
l'accompagnent en conditionnant 20 à 30
% des paiements directs à des mesures
environnementales et en même temps elle
les impose à tous les états membres et
le fait d'avoir aujourd'hui des mesures
environnementales imposées à tous les
états membres
c'est ça qui nous permet d'arrêter cette
spirale infernale où sur nos étals au
sein de notre marché commun on voit des
produits faits en europe qui ne respecte
pas les mêmes normes environnementales
et ça ça n'est clairement plus possible
et cette politique agricole commune
enfin prend le chemin de cette
convergence dans les normes
environnementales
alors oui au même moment j'ai entendu
comme vous certains appels ne pas voter
pour cette politique agricole commune
j'ai entendu ces apôtres de
l'incantation et jamais de l'action qui
depuis leur salon disait ne votez pas
cette politique agricole commune
alors moi je leur pose une question je
le dis clairement dans quel secteur
d'activité aujourd'hui avant nous
une transformation ou 20 à 30 % des
paiements est conditionnée à des mesures
environnementales dans quel autre
secteur d'activité
c'est dans l'agriculture et nous devons
le saluer et encourager être fiers de
nos agriculteurs la parole de monsieur
françois michel lambert merci merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre du
travail 59 me 52000 nouvelles
contaminations ont été enregistrées en
une seule journée
combien dans les entreprises dans les
transports en commun dans les écoles
face à cette seconde vague on évoque
certaines pistes au confinement
partielle ou totale couvre feu étendu
durci fermeture des écoles avant
d'imposer des dispositions plus
drastiques
il convient de prendre en urgence
d'autres mesures en particulier pour la
rentrée scolaire
aération des espaces enseignement à
distance allègement des effectifs des
classes il faut aussi agir sur le
télétravail et l'absence de mesures
concrètes prises par le gouvernement sur
ce point est une faute pourtant parmi
les salariés qui ont été travaillés dans
le rang le confinement est large
majorité souhaitent pouvoir continuer
mais le télétravail est en net recul de
1 travailleur sur cinq
il ne concerne aujourd'hui plus que 12 %
des heures travaillées
or on sait qu'à une plus grande échelle
permettraient de limiter
considérablement les contaminations de
plus ce travail est également un outil
d'aménagement du territoire
il ya un impact positif sur notre
environnement belgique italie pays-bas
ne s'y sont pas trompés ils ont pris des
mesures pour inciter encadrer le recours
au télétravail
ici en france on se contente
d'encourager les entreprises à y
recourir
la situation l'urgence reka mieux que
ces messages timorés
quand on voit quand on sait que 86 % des
agents publics souhaité vouloir
continuer à télétravailler
on s'étonne que le gouvernement n'ait
pas réellement favoriser le télétravail
dans la fonction publique d'état
quand on voit que la conférence sociale
sur le télétravail est bloqué face à
l'immobilisme du medef
on se doit à madame la ministre de vous
demander d'agir au plus vite
êtes vous prête à légiférer d'ici la fin
de l'année pour adapter notre droit
ainsi changer d'échelle dans la mise en
oeuvre massive du télétravail dans la
crise que nous traversons merci merci je
les budgets la parole est à monsieur
laurent pietrasinski secrétaire d'état
chargé des retraites et de la santé au
travail
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député lambert monsieur le
député lambert vous avez raison de
souligner que le télétravail est un
outil puissant et fort utile dans cette
période de crise sanitaire
d'ailleurs il ne vous a pas échappé que
cette effectivement la position du
gouvernement depuis plusieurs mois et
que le gouvernement travailler avec
l'ensemble des branches pour que ce
télétravail soit aussi la réalité pour
chaque activité qui était travaillable
en réalité monsieur le député vous avez
souligné tout à l'heure un indicateur
comparant un nombre de salariés
concernés un nombre d'heures réalisées
si vous regardez bien enquête de la
dares vous verrez qu'en fait c'est un
travailleur sur trois qui
télétravaillent et donc qu'il y à une
réalité qui est bien en progression par
rapport à ce que vous avez décrit mais
vous le savez le cadre qui a été donné
par le gouvernement dans le protocole
national de déconfinement et qui est
maintenant la règle pour l'ensemble des
entreprises à donner un cadre le cadre
il est connu il est identifié dans le
cadre d'un dialogue social de proximité
les activités qui sont télétravail abl
et à chaque fois que cela est possible
et bien d'avoir un nombre de jours fait
travaillable je pense monsieur le député
que cela a été d'ailleurs très bien dit
par monsieur le premier ministre il
avait dû garder moi même hier il faut
maintenant pousser le curseur au maximum
être en situation de proposer à chaque
fois que c'est possible
le télétravail n'oublions pas une chose
monsieur le député c'est qu'il y à une
nécessité de maintenir aussi un lien
social et cela
tous les représentants des employeurs et
des salariés nous l'ont dit nous l'ont
dit pendant cette période de
déconfinement et maintenir le lien
social
ça renvoie aussi aux responsabilités
qu'on les managers les employeurs mais
aussi les salariés entre eux de
maintenir un niveau des changes et de
proximité et cela c'est indispensable
face une crise sanitaire qui c'est vrai
que tu portes pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
merci monsieur vif avant de lui céder la
parole je voudrais saluer notre collègue
raphaël gérard que nous sommes heureux
de retrouver parmi nous en parfaite
forme
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président merci chers collègues pour
votre accueil question s'adresse à
madame roselyne bachelot ministre de la
culture
face à l'augmentation exponentielle du
nombre de nouvelles contaminations en
coronavirus qui m qui mettent notre
système hospitalier sous tension le
gouvernement a annoncé de nouvelles
restrictions dont notamment l'extension
du couvre-feu à 38 nouveaux départements
désormais ce sont près de 46 millions de
français qui sont concernés par cette
mesure de solidarité et de
responsabilité vis-à-vis de nos
soignantes et de nos soignants qui
restent mobilisés en première ligne pour
combattre le virus
ces annonces portent un nouveau coup dur
au monde de la culture déjà très
largement éprouvés par la crise
sanitaire car un satan en s'attaquant
aux formes les plus élémentaires de
sociabilité en nous empêchant de nous
rassembler d'aller à la rencontre des
artistes des auteurs des oeuvres le
corps à vie le corona virus s'attaque à
l'âme de la france son exception
culturelle
or élu d'une circonscription rurale où
l'offre culturelle est limitée ou les
horizons sociaux sont parfois empreintes
ou rétrécissement je sais à quel point
les salles de cinéma
le spectacle vivant et les festivals
sont vitaux pour nos territoires
ce sont des passerelles vers l'altérité
et des clés de voûte de l'accès à la
culture pour tous ce sont également des
secteurs économiques à forte valeur
ajoutée
représentant près de sept fois celle de
l'industrie automobile conscient de ces
enjeux le gouvernement a annoncé des
mesures exceptionnelles en soutien au
monde de la culture dès le mois de mars
il a fait de la relance culturelle une
de ses priorités avec près de 2
milliards d'euros investis au cours de
ces prochaines années
il a annoncé cet été des mesures de
soutien spécifiques nouveau au spectacle
vivant et à l'industrie audiovisuelle
mais voilà contraint de fermer les
portes des cinémas et des salles de
spectacles au mieux à 20h30
alors que liliane leur billetterie ont
déjà chuté de 30 à 50% par rapport à
septembre 2019
les acteurs de la vie culturelle
craignent le tomber de rideau final
dans ce contexte madame la ministre
pourriez-vous nous rappeler les mesures
de soutien décidées par le gouvernement
pour préserver c'est en entier de notre
vie culturelle qui plus que jamais face
aux ténèbres du virus dresde et clarté
et plantes des flambeaux à la lisière
des nuits mais si monsieur le député la
parole est à madame roselyne bachelot
ministre de la culture le ciel monsieur
le député raphael gérard les
applaudissements qui ont salué votre
intervention fonction crédit de
l'admirable parcours de militant
culturel du militant de la culture qui a
irrigué toute votre vie et notre joie
aussi de vous retrouver en pleine santé
pour poser cette question oui vous avez
raison
vous avez raison de dire que la crise
sanitaire a durement impacté le secteur
culturel
dès que la décision de couvre-feu a été
prise avec le premier ministre jean
castex
nous avons réuni les acteurs de la
culture du spectacle vivant du cinéma
pour calibrer au mieux la réponse qu'il
convenait d'apporter permettre au
secteur de continuer son action au
service des français
bien sûr l'ensemble des mesures qui ont
été prises aussi bien par bruno le maire
que par elisabeth bornes s'applique à ce
secteur de la culture
que ce soit le chômage partiel at au
maximum le fonds de solidarité l'aide
aux loyers ainsi que toutes les mesures
comme les prêts garantis par l'état
mais ce secteur avait aussi besoin de
mesures spécifiques nous les avons
prises pour le cinéma puisque à peu près
la moitié de son chiffre d'affaires est
réalisé en soirée c'est ainsi que 30
millions d'euros ont été dédiés pour
l'ensemble de la filière que ce soit les
exploitants les distributeurs ou les
producteurs et puis aussi c'est le
spectacle vivant 85 millions d'euros ont
été dédiées aux spectacles vivants 55
millions d'euros pour les fonds de
solidarité de sauvegarde
nous avons également supprimer le
versement de la taxe sur les spectacles
pendant le premier semestre de l'année
2000 21 20 millions d'euros vont aller
directement au théâtre qu'ils soient
privés ou qu'il soit du secteur public
et également 5 millions d'euros qui vont
venir abonder un fonds d'urgence qui
vont être dans à qui va être ainsi
portée à 10 millions d'euros
c'est donc au total 5,1 millions d'euros
qui vont être d'aider le spect au
spectacle vivant et au cinéma et nous
continuerons si nous voyons que la
situation sanitaire sa grappe nous
adapterons encore ces mesures fines
lames la mairie
la parole de monsieur pierre cordier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
nous avons été nombreux sur ses bancs
avoir été alerté par des pharmaciens et
des concitoyens qui sont très inquiets
concernant les vaccins contre la grippe
après la cacophonie sur les masques
voilà la cacophonie sur les vaccins la
direction générale de la santé a déjà
communiqué sur un risque de pénurie en
demandant aux pharmaciens de privilégier
les patients à risque notamment les
personnes de plus de 65 ans et les
personnels de santé ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est à l'ère de la dgs a créé un
mouvement de rue et des patients dans
les 48 heures du démarrage de la
campagne
ainsi en deux jours les pharmaciens ont
vendu l'équivalent de tout le mois
d'octobre ce qui compte tenu des
livraisons non complète à créer la
pénurie est la panique
le solde de la première commande de
vaccins n'est toujours pas arrivée dans
les pharmacies la seconde partie de ses
commandes qui devait être livré avant
fin octobre n'arrivera à priori que fin
novembre
les pharmaciens ne peuvent donc pas
délivrer les vaccins à tous les patients
même s'ils sont prioritaires je pense
notamment aux personnels des ehpad ou
aux aidants à domicile qui doivent
impérativement pouvoir se faire vacciner
pour se protéger et protéger nos aînés
j'ai donc trois questions monsieur le
ministre pourquoi 11 millions de doses
ont été commandées
alors que la sécurité sociale a délivré
16 millions de bons pour les personnes
vulnérables et les professionnels de
santé
deuxième question pouvez-vous nous dire
où sont allés les vaccins qui n'ont pas
été livrées aux pharmacies fin septembre
troisième question avez vous réellement
commandé deux millions de vaccins cet
été où avez vous pris sur le stock qui
avait été précommandée en janvier 2020
par les pharmaciens de nos territoires
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à madame brigitte
bourguignon ministre délégué chargé de
l'autonomie merci de votre accueil
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
pierre cordier
je vous remercie de votre question qui
me permet de faire un point légèrement
plus mesuré sur la situation sanitaire
relative à la grippe a la campagne de
vaccination a débuté le 13 octobre
dernier
elle vise en priorité les populations
fragiles et ceux qui les soignent comme
chaque année la commande de doses est
faite par les officines au mois de mars
pour l'épidémie de l'hiver suivant
cette commande se fonde sur la
consommation de doses de l'année a passé
avec un objectif évidemment réhaussée
par exemple en 2019 seul un tiers des
professionnels en ehpad été vaccinées
nous devons évidemment faire mieux dans
le contexte de l'épidémie qu'ovide pour
éviter que le système de santé n'est à
faire face à l'afflux de patients le
gouvernement a passé pour la première
fois commandes aux laboratoires afin
d'augmenter de 30% le nombre de doses
disponibles en complément des 13
millions de doses de circuits habituels
au 24 octobre 5,3 millions de doses ont
été vendues par les officines plus de
80% il faut écouter de vaccination sont
faites auprès des personnes âgées de
plus de revenus que ces chiffres
correspondent aux nous devrions nous
féliciter tous ensemble face à cela nous
avons en effet pu observer quelques
tensions d'approvisionnement des
pharmacies en doses à ce jour 16 % des
officines pharmaceutiques y sont
confrontées cette demande précoce
entraîne des tensions dans la livraison
toutefois les stocks sont là et les
livraisons sont en cours pour
reconstituer le stock des officines sur
cette seule semaine
réd 1,3 million de doses seront livrées
en pharmacie c'est ma réponse je vous
assure donc monsieur le député qu'un
suivi territoriale a été mis en place
aux liens avec leurs national des
pharmaciens afin de trouver des
solutions rapides en cas de difficultés
bon monsieur monsieur cordier vous avez
quelques secondes je propose donc que
vos collègues vous laisse parler
puisqu'il n'est cependant la réponse
vous avez la parole simplement madame la
ministre vous n'avez absolument pas
répondu à mes trois questions nos
concitoyens les pharmaciens lé personnel
des ehpad apprécieront merci chers
collègues
la parole est à monsieur mot était ivre
au personnes merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs du gouvernement
chers collègues il ya parfois des
moments de grâce dans cette assemblée
qu'on nous écoutons pour comprendre et
pas pour répondre j'en reviens à ma
question
la polynésie française comme l'ensemble
de la république fait face à cette crise
sanitaire
hier nous avons dépassé en nombre absolu
de décès ceux de la nouvelle zélande
pays de cinq millions d'habitants
nous sommes 2 172 milles en polynésie le
nombre de lits en réanimation va d'ici
deux semaines peut-être trois semaines
se révéler totalement insuffisant mais
le plus important c'est les ressources
humaines alors
j'ai bien conscience que la réserve
sanitaire nationale ne pourra pas être
mobilisés outre-mer parce qu'on en a
besoin ici dans l'hexagone les chiffres
sont là
ma question porte sur la coopération
régionale et internationale
vous savez monsieur le ministre qu'il
existe des accords dits accords france
dans le pacifique
france australie nouvelle zélande vous
savez aussi que c'est des pays-bas
nouvelle-zélande et l'australie dispose
de personnel médical de réanimation
compétents rigoni par l' oms nous avons
eu également un compte et jean
contingent des médecins qui va qui a été
envoyé en martinique
la question est donc simple est ce que
l'état est ce que vous êtes prêts à
soutenir le gouvernement polynésien pour
demander à cette coopération régionale
et internationale de venir aider la
polynésie française en double file
merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame brigitte
bourguignon ministre délégué chargé de
l'autonomie merci monsieur le président
messieurs mesdames et messieurs le
député monsieur le député bros ayrton je
vous remercie pour votre question
l'évolution de l'épidémie est en effet
très préoccupante en polynésie française
et nous sommes collectivement mobiliser
sachez le le nombre de cas actifs a plus
que doublé en une semaine il y a eu 17
au split et hospitalisations
supplémentaires sur cette période et le
nombre de personnes en réanimation a
pratiquement doublé en sept jours + 7
soit plus d'une vingtaine actuellement
c'est un taux d'incidence de 500 cas
pour 100000 habitants c'est exorbitant
nous devons aussi déploré le décès de 20
personnes dont six au cours de la
dernière semaine
les autorités sanitaires sont en lien
direct et continu avec les autorités de
polliniser française pour suivre cette
épidémie bien sûr plusieurs rencontres
ont été organisées d'ailleurs avec les
maires les responsables de cultes les
organisations syndicales est l'objectif
principal de ces rencontres est de
présenter les mesures applicables dans
le cadre de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
la majorité des interlocuteurs
tâche cette importance d'une mesure
forte pour enrayer la progression de
nombreux soutiens ont déjà été mobilisés
depuis le début de la crise notamment en
matériel et en renforts humains les
besoins exprimés par le haut commissaire
le président fritsch fin août ont été
rapidement satisfaits et font l'objet
d'un continue de suivi rigoureux par le
centre de crise je pense aux réserve
sanitaire donc que vous évoquez aux
équipements de protection individuelle
et à l'appui de commandes en réactifs et
en extracteur leur appui a permis
d'identifier les leviers d'optimisation
dans l'organisation et dans la gestion
des ressources disponibles
la question d'un appui supplémentaire
est en cours de discussion nous sommes
favorables et d'analystes bien sûr un
des enjeux portent également sur la
disponibilité des tests en nombre
suffisant afin de tester plus largement
plus rapidement la population et limiter
la diffusion du virus notamment dans les
archipels
je peux donc vous assurez monsieur lui
le député pardon pour conclure que le
centre de crise est pleinement mobilisée
merci la parole à monsieur brahim un
mouche monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
la crise est d'une magnitude sans
précédent on compterait ainsi 1 millions
de nouveaux pauvres en raison de la
crise liée à la colite 19
les associations voient affluer dans
leurs locaux des étudiants intérimaire
chômeurs mais aussi et cela reste inédit
des auto entrepreneurs et des artisans
des personnes qui étaient jusqu alors
éloigné de la pauvreté et qui s'ajoute
aux 9,3 millions de personnes vivent
déjà au dessus du seuil de la pauvreté
les bénéficiaires de l'aide alimentaire
ont augmenté de 30% les demandeurs de
rsa de 20% dans tous les aspects de la
vie quotidienne de la subsistance à
l'accès aux soins ou à l'éducation
ses concitoyens sont confrontés à des
arbitral quotidien est parfois des
renoncements important manger ou se
chauffer soigner ses dents ou acheter un
vêtement pour l'hiver réparer sa voiture
pour chercher du travail ou payer son
loyer
en plus des privations matérielles et de
droit inacceptable dans notre pays
ses compatriotes vivent en permanence en
insécurité sans qu'il leur soit toujours
possible de se projeter vers un avenir
meilleur
monsieur le ministre léon bourgeois
l'écrivez la liberté humaine est un
principe le droit à l'existence en état
aussi nécessairement antérieure à tout
autre et l'état doit le garantir avant
tout autre dans ce contexte de kuran au
virus
l'état est au rendez vous comme nul
autre comparativement à ses voisins
ainsi déconfinement l'état a soutenu le
pouvoir d'achat des plus précaires
le plan de relance a prolongé cet effort
indispensable de solidarité par une
nouvelle dotation de 6 milliards d'euros
vous avez annoncé un acte 2 du plan
pauvreté qui abondent au raid 1,8
milliard d'euros les 8 milliards d'euros
initialement prévus pouvez vous nous
détailler le contenu de ces mesures de
prévention et de lutte contre la bascule
dans la pauvreté
au nom de ce droit à l'existence pour
les gars dignité de la personne humaine
en cédant difficile et sous les auspices
de notre république sociale je vous
remercie
merci monsieur débuté la parole à madame
brigitte bourguignon ministre délégué
chargé de l'autonomie merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs le
député monsieur le député brahim
hammouche cham je vous remercie de cette
question qui me donne l'opportunité de
revenir sur le plan du gouvernement pour
prévenir la bascule de nos concitoyens
dans la pauvreté m c'est très agréable
ce genre de commentaire c'est un petit
but et qui compte tenu de son caractère
transversal mobilisant
le président de la république a fixé un
cap clair en 2018 mettre un terme à
cette rose nombreuses situations de
pauvreté qui se hisse hausse qui
s'offrent en héritage dans le contexte
de crise que nous connaissons notre
action était immédiate pour maintenir
l'activité économique et les emplois qui
lui sont liés l'activité partielle
permettent en effet de protéger les
emplois et donc à la fois évidemment de
préserver le pouvoir d'achat de nombreux
ménages tout en offrant une adaptabilité
salvatrice à nos entreprises le premier
ministre a présenté ce week end au delà
de ces mesures que vous connaissez déjà
un nouveau plan d'action autour de trois
grandes priorités soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des prêts de personnes précaires
avec une aide exceptionnelle de 150
euros pour les jeunes non étudiants et
pour les étudiants boursiers favoriser
la sortie de la pauvreté en développant
des solutions d'insertion sociale et
professionnelle et d'activités pour les
personnes éloignées de l'emploi
notamment avec le doublement des
parcours d'emploi compétences dans les
culs pv et les zones de revitalisation
rurale avec un financement de l'état qui
passe de 40 à 80 % assurer des
conditions de logement aussi et
d'hébergement adapté prévenir les
impayés de loyer et notamment la
prolongation de l'aide versée par action
logement de 150 euros pour prévenir les
impayés de loyer au total près de 2
milliards d'euros sont donc mobilisés
pour financer les mesures nouvelles de
lutte contre la pauvreté qui s'ajoute
aux 8 milliards du budget de la
stratégie antérieure le gouvernement
prend donc la pleine mesure de la crise
économique qui découle de la crise
sanitaire et ne laissera aucun français
sur le bord du chemin
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur gérard le seul merci merci
monsieur président ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le premier ministre et j'ai
bien entendu la réponse qui vient d'être
faite la france s'enfoncer un peu plus
dans la crise économique et sociale et
votre gouvernement restent timorées lent
et sourd pour venir en aide aux plus
précaires qui sont les premiers touchés
par la récession le plan de relance
discute encore hier soir en séance à
cordes 22 milliards de crédits pour 2021
tout est concentré sur la politique de
l'offre
seulement 0 8% sont concentrés au
soutien des plus précaires
votre plan de relance ne parle
effectivement pas d'urgence les débats
d'hier soir et les annonces de samedi
dernier ne répondent effectivement pas
situation dramatique que vivent de trop
nombreux concitoyens temporaire et
limitée vos mesures s'inscrivent dans la
droite ligne de la politique menée
depuis 2010 est considérant que veut
revaloriser des minima sociaux
freineraient le retour à l'emploi
vos choix relève d'une logique dépasser
consistant à opposer des bons pauvres
ceux à qui l'on donnerait un coup de
pouce pour les aider à retrouver le
marché de l'emploi et les mauvais
pauvres à kg distribuerez quelques euros
les bénéficiaires du rsa dont le nombre
va croître de près de 9% et ceux de
l'allocation spécifique de solidarité
les jeunes de moins de 25 ans et les
étudiants boursiers ne percevront fin
novembre décembre que qu'une aide
exceptionnelle de 150 euros
ce n'est pas suffisant et cela ne répond
pas à l'urgence de la situation
votre gouvernement reste sur une
position idéologique en refusant
d'augmenter les minima sociaux une
revalorisation est d'autant plus
nécessaire que le rsa n'atteint plus
aujourd'hui que 39 % du smic contre 50
pour cent quatre-vingt-huit au moment de
sa création il faut donner un coup de
pouce significatif aux minima sociaux
il faut au moins 100 euros par mois il
faut aider aussi tous ceux qui n'ont pas
droit au rsa et notamment les plus
jeunes ceux de moins de 25 ans pour
lesquels nous avions proposé un minimum
de jeunesse comment monsieur le ministre
pensez vous faire pour lutter
efficacement contre la pauvreté en
refusant ces mesures de bon sens
alors que demain vous allez annoncer un
durcissement des mesures t la parole à
madame brigitte bourguignon ministre
délégué chargé de l'autonomie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député le seul permettez-moi de faire
suite à la réponse que j'ai déjà donné
précédemment à monsieur hammouche peu de
vous dire que agir contre la pauvreté
c'est agir tout d'abord pour l'insertion
par l'activité auprès des personnes les
plus éloignées de l'emploi
c'est les accompagner socialement pour
connaître bien ce sujet je peux vous
dire que ça n'est pas simple parfois que
de tenir la main de quelqu'un qui est
très éloignées de l'emploi
c'est ça agir contre la pauvreté agir
contre la provôté c'est aussi faire en
sorte que l'accès au droit soit le plus
amélioré possible et c'est ce que nous
allons faire agir contre la pauvreté
c'est trouver des solutions
d'hébergement pour la pour lutter contre
la précarité est en ce moment dans le
contexte de crise sanitaire c'est
d'autant plus important vous imaginez
bien agir contre la pauvreté c'est
s'occuper des jeunes et les jeunes en
priorité et les jeunes d'ailleurs qu'on
ne doit pas mettre de suite dans les
minima sociaux
et vous faites partie d'une formation
politique monsieur je vais vous le
rappeler parce que je sais qui a
toujours prôné justement l'activité
d'abord l'insertion l'apprentissage bien
avant d'entrer dans les minima sociaux
j'en veux pour preuve la création du rmi
je sais très bien qu elle n'a jamais
concerné les moins de 25 ans et que ç'a
toujours été même un credo de cette
formation politique vous le savez parce
que on s'émancipe socialement par le
travail par les études par la formation
et par l'activité
donc moi je crois plus fortement à ces
vecteurs qui peuvent lutter contre la
pauvreté
plutôt que d'aider e puis je veux bien
en tout cas sachez que nous avons aussi
à ajouter dans les mesures que nous
avons pris dans la lutte contre la
provôté 9 millions de masques ont été
envoyés aux familles les plus
défavorisées
il faut le dire il faut le rappeler est
certaine aussi création d' équipes
mobiles de visites à domicile ont été
amorcées pour les familles menacées
d'expulsion vous le voyez nous avons mis
donc en place tout un panel de mesures
qui visent à accompagner à insérer et
surtout à éviter les récidives
voilà merci madame la ministre la parole
est à monsieur robert rôdât
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
vous connaissez le slogan la france est
dans l'air malheureusement ce moment le
pavillon aérien français est clouée sur
le sol de nos aéroports depuis huit mois
la crise sanitaire est dévastatrice pour
le secteur de l'aérien le trafic est en
chute libre
rien que pour les aéroports de paris 75
% de passagers en moins et 13 milliards
de pertes chaque mois à ce rythme que va
devenir le transport aérien
que vont devenir nos aéroports nos
compagnies aériennes aux infrastructures
notre industrie aéronautique
nous sous traitants nos assistants en
escale le commerçant nos entreprises de
sûreté de sécurité ou encore nos
services de contrôle public
que vont devenir les près de cent mille
personnes qui chaque jour connecte les
âmes et les territoires notre secteur
aérien nous a prêté main forte
lorsqu on en avait besoin il nous a
prêté sa force logistique au plus haut
de la crise sanitaire
il est urgent de lui prêter à nouveau ma
forte sur le plan sanitaire le
gouvernement à réagir rebonds autorisons
enfin dans nos aéroports a effectué des
tests antigénique au départ pour les
passagers mais malgré l'appel des
professionnels du secteur à ce jour le
dispositif reste embryonnaire à
marseille à nice ou à orly où il
commence tout juste à être expérimentée
qui plus est ces tests antigénique ne
sont pas reconnus par la plupart des
autres pays sur le plan économique alors
que plane le risque d'un confinement
l'aérien ne survivra pas une seconde
vague des conséquences vont être durable
et historique le plus grand risque est
que les françaises et les français
soient confinés au sol pendant des
années faute d'avoir pu maintenir nos
connexions aériennes
monsieur le premier ministre à l'heure
où votre gouvernement lance son plan de
relance pour nos emplois pour nos
territoires
comment allez-vous intervenir comment
allez-vous intervenir pour sauver le
secteur aérien nos aéroports nos
compagnies aériennes je vous remercie
merci monsieur débuté la parole comme
alan barbara pour piliers ministre la
transition écologique
merci merci monsieur président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député robert hedin comme
vous nous sommes évidemment préoccupés
nous regardons de près la situation du
monde aérien français et notamment la
situation des aéroports et des
entreprises dans les aéroports comme
vous l'avez dit nous avons pris et nous
prenons toutes les mesures sanitaires
tout d'abord parce que c'est celle
essentielle pour limiter au maximum les
risques au sein des aérogares au sein
des aéronefs que ce soit pour les
personnels ou pour les voyageurs il ya
des des zones de grand passage des
aéroports qui sont désinfectés plusieurs
fois par jour le port du masque a été
rendue obligatoire nous et nous
utilisons des systèmes de répartition
des passagers pour aix passer au maximum
les passagers dans les avions les
compagnons la possibilité de prendre la
température des passagers avant
l'embarquement des centres de tests ont
été mis en place et notamment nous
progressons vous l'avez dit l'aéroport
de marseille provence propose
aujourd'hui
depuis lundi des tests antigénique
gratuit pour les passagers volontaires
en partenariat puisque tout ça se fait
en partenariat avec l' ars paca la
préfecture des bouches du rhône et les
résultats de ces tests sont transmis aux
voyageurs en moins de 20 minutes et nous
devrions pouvoir généraliser ces tests
rapides le plus rapidement possible sur
le plan économique
nous sommes également très attentif le
trafic aérien est très perturbé
actuellement il se situe environ 40 % de
son niveau de 2019
il devrait retrouver son niveau dc 22000
23 2024 nous soulignons par ailleurs que
89 % des vols vers l'outre-mer sont
assurés pour assurer cette ce lien très
fort que nous avons avec nos outre mer
le secteur aérien fait face à une grave
crise
vous connaissez les mesures pour aider
le secteur aérien le chômage partiel les
prêts garantis par l'état des mesures de
report de charge sur le plan social nous
sommes vigilants à préserver l'emploi et
des salariés je pense en particulier à
adp ou le dialogue social avance bien et
nous avons un accord de méthode
prévoyant de négocier jusqu'à la fin du
mois d'octobre
nous accompagnons dialogue social
partout et nous aidons le secteur a
évolué pour être plus fort demain plus
compétitive plus écologiques à travers
le plan de soutien l'aéronautique ces 15
milliards d'euros dette d'investissement
de prêts et de garanties nous sommes aux
côtés du secteur r
pour qu'il soit demain le fleuron de
l'aéronautique et merci à la parole est
à monsieur robert rôdât même laminé
puisque c'est vous qui m'avez répondu
j'en profite simplement pour dire que
s'il ya bien un secteur économique qui
est capable de transition énergétique
est capable d'innovation c'est le
secteur de l'aérien
il faut lui faire toute confiance et
être contre tout les touts les anathèmes
qui combattent aujourd'hui le transport
aérien nécessaire pour connecter nos
vies notre monde nos territoires
le but est la parole comme j'aime gidel
guerrab merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre ritz terre we are
one nous sommes unis c'est par ces mots
que le président de la république a
prolongé l'hommage national rendu à la
sorbonne en l'honneur du professeur
samuel pâtit lâchement assassiné par un
terroriste islamiste
car oui le terrorisme tu en france mais
ils tuent également dans les pays
musulmans
cet été dans ma circonscription il a ôté
la vie de huit humanitaires qui oeuvrait
pour un idéal de paix et de coopération
au niger
avant-hier il a encore durement frappé
l'afghanistan faisant plus de 24 morts
cela m'amène à voir de réflexion
premièrement la communauté
internationale doit plus que jamais
s'unir pour lutter contre le terrorisme
en renforçant notamment ses efforts pour
l'accès à l'éducation
deuxièmement elle a hésité française est
encore trop souvent mal comprises à
l'extérieur de nos frontières
le mouvement de boycott des produits
français qui sévit actuellement dans bon
nombre de pays musulmans et les paroles
outrancières du président turc en sont
la malheureuse expression ainsi à chaque
fois que cela est nécessaire nous devons
le rappeler de manière apaisée que la
laïcité d'abord et avant tout une
liberté comme l'a souhaité aristide
briand ici dans cet hémicycle
je reprendrai donc ces mots qui
définissent la laïcité comme la liberté
de croire ou de ne pas croire la liberté
pour celles et ceux qui croient de
pratiquer librement leur religion
tant qu'elle ne fait pas obstacle à la
loi de la république
votre groupe
et à travers lui la représentation
nationale apporte donc un soutien ferme
entier au président de la république qui
n'a fait que redire une évidence la
liberté ou la chérissons l'égalité ou la
garantie sont la fraternité nous la
vivons avec intensité
ainsi monsieur le ministre quel sera
l'action du gouvernement pour garantir
la laïcité à l'intérieur de nos
frontières
et pour mieux expliquer à nos
partenaires internationaux ce concept
merci merci monsieur le député la parole
est à monsieur gérald darmanin ministre
de l'intérieur merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député majid el guerrab il
est évident que votre question reflète
trois sujets le premier celui de la
protection de nos concitoyens à
l'extérieur de nos frontières
les lycées français les ambassades les
consulats les intérêts économiques
les citoyens qui simplement sont allés
vivre dans des territoires en dehors des
territoires de la république c'est leur
droit le plus strict indoor devons
protection en rien bien sûr avec les
autorités qui les accueillent et franck
riester ainsi que jean-yves le drian je
sais travailler à cette protection est
en mis en alerte un certain nombre de
dispositifs poursuivi un jardin c'est
d'ailleurs et forces armées ou les
policiers les gendarmes qui sont à la
disposition de nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens à l'étranger
le deuxième sujet évidemment la force
des valeurs françaises est parmi les
forces des valeurs françaises il ya
évidemment la liberté la liberté de
culte la liberté de croire ou ne pas
croire
la liberté de pouvoir caricature et de
se moquer et peut-être que ces libertés
à commencer par la valeur la plus
française qui soit qu'est la laïcité et
nos temps plus difficiles à comprendre
vous l'avez dit monsieur députés qu'elle
est unique mais c'est la vocation de la
france d'avoir une un message universel
c'est la vocation de la france que de
pouvoir porter haut des valeurs qui ont
fait maturité après
dizaine d'années de combat politique et
nous ne devons pas abdiquer de notre
originalité parce que cette en france
monsieur le député vous le savez bien
que des dizaines de milliers de
personnes trouvent refuge parce qu'ils
sont eux-mêmes persécuté par des
dictatures islamistes
c'est dans la france d'aujourd'hui que
des milliers de femmes sont accueillies
je pense au fameux yézidis nomades
allemagne a pas rendu visite tout à
l'heure merci à toutes celles qui fuient
les dictatures islamistes la pressions
communautaristes pour pouvoir porter les
cheveux au vent s'il le souhaite et
c'est pour ces valeurs là que beaucoup
de gens se battent dans le monde que
nous devons absolument pouvoir continuer
à les infirmer
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur alain david
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères le
week-end dernier a été marqué par une
passe d'armes peu diplomatiques entre le
président de la république française et
le président turc erdogan après l'avoir
diffamé ce dernier a même encouragé au
boycott des produits et entreprises
françaises au motif de la déclaration
des manuels macron qui défend des la
république la liberté d'expression et la
laïcité
le président turc cherche ainsi à
toucher l'opinion publique de son pays
et plus généralement le monde musulman
cherchant à s'imposer en leader de ces
derniers il cherche aussi à tourner la
page de l'orientation pro-occidental
liés à l'héritage du fondateur de la
turquie moderne mustafa kamel kamal
d'eau également sa volonté
ces dernières années d' imposer son
ordre en syrie en libye et dans le nord
de l'irak en méditerranée orientale son
armée ne cesse d'attiser les tensions
avec la grèce ou chypre plus récemment
il a soutenu l'azerbaïdjan le pays
turcophones frère en guerre contre l'
enclave arménienne du haut karabagh ces
manoeuvres sont liées à la volonté de
monsieur erdogan de relever sa
popularité
on peut alors craindre qu'ils se lancent
dans une surenchère religieuse et
militaire afin de jouer sur le sentiment
patriotique de ses concitoyens
nous soutenons évidemment les
engagements du président macron en
faveur de la laïcité de la liberté
d'expression nous condamnons les propos
du président erdogan s'en faire
l'amalgamme entre son dirigeant et le
peuple turc qui mérite toute notre
sympathie
mais monsieur le ministre au delà du
rappel de notre ambassadeur
quelles initiatives diplomatiques
entendez-vous prendre afin de faire
baisser la tension avec ce pays voisin
de l'europe aux liens forts avec la
france tant sur le plan historique
qu'économique
merci chers collègues parole est à
monsieur franck riester ministre délégué
chargé du commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député david mesdames et messieurs les
députés
que faire face au comportement du
président r doan et à ses manoeuvres
pour étendre son influence au delà de
ses frontières et pourra essayer de
faire passer son sa détermination a
justement développer son influence
partout dans le monde sur le dos d'un
soi-disant confrontation avec le
président macron on est bien loin de
cette réalité là il s'agit d'un problème
de fond majeures la détermination de la
france à donc à défendre ses valeurs et
défendre ses intérêts au sein de
l'europe est totale et nous pensons
qu'il faut renforcer le rapport de force
avec le président erdogan
pour cela il faut traite unis et
l'europe est unie regardez les
manifestations de soutien pour vers la
france de tous les pays européens la
france est uni et la france est uni
l'europe est unie et lors du prochain
conseil de l'union européenne
l'europe devra prendre les décisions qui
lui permettra de renforcer son rapport
de force avec la turquie pour mieux
défendre ses intérêts mieux défendre les
valeurs européennes parce qu'au delà
encore une fois de l' influence
grandissante potentiel de la turquie il
en va de l'avenir des valeurs de notre
europe celle que nous partageons avec
tous les pays européens
il faut être ferme et unie je les
rappeler tout à l'heure et la france
sera évidemment à l'initiative tout en
étant déterminé aussi apaisée
les relations avec la turquie est ferme
être déterminé à agir avec tous les
moyens pour renforcer les rapports de
force au niveau européen et en même
temps essayer de trouver les voies et
moyens pour davantage de dialogue est
davantage d'apaisement avec ce grand
partenaire qui doit rester la turquie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur david lorion seul président
monsieur le ministre affaires étrangères
je voudrais vous parler d'un immense
drame qui se joue aujourd'hui sur une
grande île qu'est l'île de madagascar la
sécheresse chronique dans le sud de la
grande île a été cette année
particulièrement sévère elle est
d'ailleurs à l'île de la réunion aussi
depuis neuf mois dans le sud de
madagascar pas une seule goutte d'eau
l'absence de récolte entraînés une
famine qui touche plus d'un million de
personnes
cent vingt mille enfants de moins de 5
ans aujourd'hui se trouve en situation
de malnutrition aiguë cette famine
devrait bientôt atteindre le stade iv
selon la classification de l'onu
correspondre à une forte insécurité
alimentaire et la nécessité d'une
assistance d'urgence
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
cette population meurt de faim face à
cette situation il ya eu un élan de
solidarité d'humanité remarquable à la
réunion et à mayotte
l'association ker et à fédérer la
mobilisation de soutien des jeunes et de
générosité des médias des collectivités
locales des citoyens comme des religieux
mais monsieur le ministre la france est
présente dans l'océan indien avec plus
d'un million de français qui vivent
nous avons des intérêts que vous
connaissez bien au nord du canal de
mozambique mais nous avons aussi un
devoir de solidarité avec les
populations du sud malgache dont une
partie est encore francophone cette
solidarité avec la grande île peut-être
une initiative de la france
elle peut prendre deux formes l'urgence
avec les aides alimentaires
l'intervention de la plate forme
régionale de l'océan indien
la plateforme piroi qui est prête à
intervenir mais elle doit aussi prendre
la forme de l'aide technique d'un plan
de développement pour l'adduction d'eau
dans le sud de madagascar pour lequel
lille 2
la réunion un savoir-faire une
ingénierie et une proximité de par son
histoire et de par sa géographie
madagascar a plus de lien avec la france
qu'avec aucun autre pays du monde
monsieur le ministre je souhaite savoir
si vous comptez prendre une initiative
diplomatique pour sauver les populations
du sud malgache de la famille et de la
mort merci monsieur débuté la parole à
monsieur franck riester ministre délégué
chargé du commerce extérieur et de
l'attractivité
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
lorient vous avez raison la sécheresse
dans le sud de madagascar est très
préoccupante
la france est mobilisée très mobilisés
auprès des autorités et du peuple
malgache face à ce défi considérable
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure des
d'humanitaires nous avons participé à
hauteur d'un million d'euros en 2020 à
la mise en oeuvre des d'humanitaire par
plusieurs organisations humanitaires
notamment dans le cadre du plan
alimentaire mondiale et à d'autres
associations ou aux ong qui travaillent
à madagascar comme action contre la faim
nous travaillons dans le cadre de
coopération décentralisée et vous le
savez tout particulièrement monsieur le
député à travers l'engagement de
collectivités dans l'océan indien
puisque nous avons mobilisé cinq cent
trente mille euros au moins d'octobre
deux cent mille euros du département de
la réunion cent trente mille euros de la
région réunion et 200000 euros du
département de mayotte
d'autre part le gouvernement malgache
pourrait mobiliser vous le savez des
prêts de contingence pour la gestion des
risques de catastrophes octroyé par l'
agence française de développement à
hauteur de 10 millions d'euros en prêts
et 1 millions 2,1 millions 5,2 euros en
subventions pour fès pour faire face à
cette crise terrible dans le sud de
madagascar enfin nous sommes également
engagés dans la durée puisque nous
sommes engagés à travers le grand plan
de développement portés par l' agence
française de développement à travers
plusieurs projets pour un total de 7
millions d'euros notamment
dans le domaine des réseaux d'eau dans
le domaine du développement agricole et
de l'amélioration de la sécurité
alimentaire
vous voyez monsieur le député la france
est engagée pleinement aux côtés des
autorités malgaches face à cette crise
sans précédent merci merci monsieur le
ministre la parole madame monique iborra
merci monsieur président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre chargée
de l'autonomie depuis des mois les
députés de la majorité mais pas
seulement ont relayé auprès des pouvoirs
publics les inquiétudes les attentes et
l'urgence exprimée par les
professionnels du secteur de l'aide à
domicile intervenant auprès des
personnes âgées des personnes
handicapées
la problématique majeure que rencontrent
les services d'aidé et d'accompagnement
à domicile depuis plusieurs années et
qui a été mise en exergue par l'épidémie
de lakovic 19 concernent le recrutement
et le maintien dans l'emploi des
salariés d'intervention et plus
largement le manque d'attractivité des
muletiers du domicile
cette situation aubert de plus en plus
significativement leur possibilité
d'accompagner les personnes en perte
d'autonomie
d'autre part des travaux menés depuis
plusieurs années maintenant
dans le cadre de la préparation de la
loi grand âge et autonomie tant attendus
ont démontré si besoin en était le
souhait d'une majorité de français de
rester à domicile quel que soit leur
avancée en âge
la semaine dernière lors de l'examen en
première lecture du projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale pour
2021 exceptionnelle à de nombreux égards
nous avons voté à l'unanimité un
financement de 200 millions d'euros par
an pour le secteur en insistant sur la
nécessité de frais chez ses moyens en
priorité sur des hausses de salaires
indispensable en effet il faut rappeler
que les salaires de base des premiers
niveaux d'emploi sont inférieurs au smic
dans plusieurs conventions collectives
dans ce contexte pensez vous madame la
ministre
en concertation avec les conseils
départementaux dont c'est la compétence
pouvoir prioriser la rebelle
organisations salariales de ses
personnels et faire en sorte comme ça
elle bénéficie légitimement de la
reconnaissance qu'elles sont en droit
d'attendre
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole à madame brigitte bourguignon
ministre délégué chargé de l'autonomie
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée monique iborra merci pour cette
question qui me permet de mettre en
lumière encore une fois les aides à
domicile et le travail qu'il faut et je
pense que la représentation nationale a
tout à gagner à l'honorer et a salué son
action notamment au quotidien mais aussi
encore plus fort en cas de crise
sanitaire et l'est d'autant plus en ce
moment on ne peut rester sans rien faire
effectivement pour ces personnes qui
depuis des années dans les conventions
collectives menées certains d'entre eux
à être payés en deçà du smig
ce n'était pas pensable c'est pourquoi
en lien avec la majorité parlementaire
le gouvernement a intégré par voie
d'amendement au plfss 2021 la création
d'une dotation de 200 millions d'euros
qui a été votée sur tous les bancs et je
pense que c'est assez rare pour qu'on
puisse le salut et sans polémiques
inutiles
cet amendement adopté donc à la nuitée a
été de surcroît comme j'ai pu le
rappeler en séance a permis d'agréer
aussi l'avant l'avenant 44 à la
convention collective de la branche des
aides à domicile concrètement c'est déjà
une augmentation opposable de 2 5% de la
valeur du point d'eau rémunération des
salaires de référence en suivant la même
méthode de concertation avec les
départements que pour le développement
de la prime qu'ovide aux aides à
domicile j'ai appelé les départements et
les fédérations à un vrai pour
travailler sur l'avenant 43 et
poursuivre la revalorisation de ce
métier améliorer son activité je dirais
qu'on nous allons poursuivre aussi cette
action à travers la réforme bien sûr du
grand âge et l'attractivité des métiers
ça passera aussi par le plan métier que
nous sommes en train de travailler
revalorisation prime qu'ovide je pense
que l'état a prouvé au département son
entière disponibilité et son ca sa
volonté de travailler en concertation et
n'aime pas l'un contre l'autre parce que
ces métiers le mérite
et ça nous apportera aussi une mais un
meilleur éclairage pour la proche
domiciliaire que nous souhaitons avoir
dans la réforme autonomie prochaine
parce que c'est le souhait des français
que de vivre à demeure et elle est
soignée d'un sinistre la parole à
monsieur bastien la chaux merci monsieur
le président dix millions dix millions
de pauvres en france dont un million de
plus depuis le début de la pandémie
plus d'un million de personnes ont été
privées d'emploi plus d'un million ont
sollicité l'aide alimentaire la fin
s'est installé dans ma circonscription
en seine-saint-denis mais plus largement
dans tout le pays
nous avons proposé la gratuité des
masques la suspension des loyers
l'encadrement des prix alimentaires le
relèvement des minimas sociaux à
commencer par le rsa et sa nécessaire
extension aux jeunes de 18 à 25 ans la
suppression du jour de carence
l'augmentation des coupons alimentaires
et des chèques énergie tout cela vous
l'avez refusé
et qu'avez-vous fait un prétendu plan
pauvreté que toutes les associations
jugent indigents vous vous moquez du
monde par pure idéologie et les
conséquences sont dramatiques
pas seulement sur le plan social mais
aussi sur le plan sanitaire car la
pauvreté est un facteur aggravant de
l'épidémie elle amplifie la
contamination et la gravité de la
maladie
les gens se contaminent parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas matériellement respecter les
consignes sanitaires
ils ne peuvent pas changer leurs masques
ils s'entassent dans des logements
insalubres ou surpeuplés
il ne se déclare pas malade de peur de
perdre leur salaire il ne peut y avoir
aucune politique sanitaire efficace sans
solidarité sociale c'est à l'état à la
solidarité nationale de prendre en
charge le soutien des personnes les plus
précaires et celles qui sont tombés dans
la pauvreté du fait du confinement mais
il ne le fait pas les associations les
militants insoumis aussi organisent des
collectes de produits de première
nécessité mais monsieur le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé ce n'est pas
à eux seuls d'assurer la solidarité
c'est à vous quand allez-vous mettre en
oeuvre les mesures d'urgence nécessaires
pour la survie immédiate
millions de personnes merci monsieur la
chaux la parole tomo si gabriel a tall
secrétaire d'état porte parole du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
le seul député à bastien la chaux ce
virus est cruel il touche est il qu il
est plus fragile il frappe vous l'avez
dit vous avez raison les plus
défavorisés c'est un fait et c'est un
fait dans le monde entier est évidemment
que dans le monde entier cette question
des conséquences économiques et sociales
de la crise sanitaire se pose
il ya peu de pays dans le monde où dans
un parlement
un gouvernement est capable de dire
qu'il a mis autant de moyens pour
répondre à cette crise sociale vous
pouvez répondre que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord que vous préfériez vous
préféreriez d'autres chemins mais dire
que le gouvernement n'a pas été devant
ses responsabilités sur ce sujet là
c'est malhonnête une prime de 150 euros
pour 4 millions de foyers pendant le
confinement 1 milliard d'euros une
augmentation de 100 euros de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire une
prime pour les jeunes leur pas un euro
pour les étudiants boursiers tous les
étudiants boursiers à l'université une
prime qui va à nouveau être versé 300
millions d'euros 2 millions d'euros en
plus pour l'hébergement social dans le
prochain budget ce sont des faits ce
sont des actes vous avez cité des
propositions que vous aviez formulée
vous aviez aussi proposé de ne pas
rouvrir les écoles et donc d'accélérer
les inégalités scolaires d'accélérer le
décrochage scolaire qui touche
prioritairement les plus fragiles vous
aviez proposé de ne pas permettre le
retour au travail et donc d'accélérer
les destructions d'emplois le chômage
première source de précarité dans notre
pays vous aviez fait ces propositions ne
vouliez pas qu'on trouve les écoles
qu'est ce qu'il en serait aujourd'hui de
l'état scolaire les familles
dans les quartiers dans les banlieues
nous avons pris nos responsabilités à
l'école assumer le encore une fois oui
il ya des drames sociaux
oui nous y répondons oui nous apportons
des moyens que le saut pour y répondre
et nous allons continuer à le faire
nous allons continuer à développer des
masques gratuits pour ceux qui en ont
besoin
nous allons continuer à revaloriser des
primes et des réponses sociales pour
ceux qui en ont besoin
parce que c'est notre responsabilité
parce que ce sont les valeurs de la
france d'être au rendez vous de cette
situation journal
merci la parole que vous admirez vous
plaît la parole est à madame mireille
robert et elle seule merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
sophie cluzel secrétaire d'état en
charge des personnes en situation de
handicap
depuis quelques années nos moins une
semaine prennent de la couleur et les
revers de novès enluminent de ruban
octobre rose et le mois de
sensibilisation dépistage du cancer du
sein et à la collecte des fonds pour
soutenir la recherche
malheureusement je crains que la copie
de 19 ans soit le fossoyeur notamment
pour celles et ceux encore éloigné des
soins comme les personnes en situation
de handicap
porter un handicap moteur mental ou
psychique ces personnes sont elles aussi
confrontée au cancer
il nous faut rendre le dépistage plus
inclusif en sensibilisant les
professionnels de soins aux spécificités
des personnes mais aussi en coordonnant
les différents intervenants du sanitaire
ce du secteur sanitaire et médico-social
dans l'aude une convention de
partenariat a été signée vendredi entre
le centre gionale de coordination des
dépistages des cancers en occitanie et
l'association afdaim adapei 11 pour que
toutes les personnes handicapées
fréquentant cet établissement est un
accès garanti au dépistage des cancers
colorectaux du sein et gynécologiques
dans cette collaboration il aura la mise
en place de formation du personnel de
l'association
une sensibilisation des médecins
généralistes et la mise
disposition d'outils de communication
adaptés madame la ministre je connais
votre engagement d'ailleurs vous aviez
confié en mission en mission en 2019 à
philippe de normandie intitulé ne pas
avoir à choisir entre être soignées ou
accompagné lorsqu'on est en situation de
handicap
la prévention passe par l'accès aux
dispositifs de dépistage organisé
madame la ministre que comptez vous
faire pour que le dépistage soit adaptée
et élargi aux personnes en situation de
handicap et que nous puissions tous
regardés confiant en l'avenir avec
l'audace d'un réel espoir merci merci mr
le député la parole à madame sophie
cluzel secrétaire d'état chargé des
personnes handicapées
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
mireille robert oui l'accès aux soins
notamment à la prévention du cancer est
un enjeu colossal pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
et force est de constater qu'en cette
crise sanitaire est encore plus
prégnante car nous avons en effet des
refus d'accès aux soins en ce moment
parce que c'est compliqué pour les
personnes handicapées quand elles sont
pas ou mal accompagné le parcours de
soins et donc entravé aujourd'hui plus
que jamais il nous faut réagir vous avez
dit le maître mot prévention action de
dépistage c'est absolument important et
c'est dans la coopération territoriale
que nous y réussiront avec les ars avec
les associations gestionnaires du médico
social avec les centres médicaux
formation prévention dépistage
alors oui nous avons confié philippe
demande au normandy ce rapport si
important pour améliorer
il y aura des annonces lors du prochain
comité interministériel du handicap fait
par le premier ministre ment sur des
mesures concrètes
deux parcours de soins d'accès à la
prévention et au dépistage
en attendant il nous faut absolument
améliorer la compréhension des personnes
en situation de handicap il ya des
initiatives fort intéressante avec santé
bd qui fait des fiches pour s'approprier
ce que c'est qu'une radiographie une
mammographie une tout simplement
comprendre comprendre et avoir le
pouvoir d'agir sur sa santé c'est un
enjeu capital
parce que en effet ne faut plus avoir à
choisir entre être soigné et être
accompagné de
les établissements médico sociaux c'est
une urgence savez vous que quand nous
dépistons une tumeur une tumeur de
cancer du sein c'est dans une femme
c'est une femme dans un établissement
médico social elle est déjà six fois
plus grosses qu'en dehors quand
politique de paul et au général donc
nous avons un urgent ce vraiment avoir
accès à cette prévention comme tout un
chacun
comprendre comment se soigner
accompagner ce sont les maîtres mots et
nous allons aller vers des mesures très
concrètes justement pour avoir un panier
de soins à la hauteur des besoins des
personnes en situation de handicap
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre la parole et à madame
frédérique dumas merci monsieur le
président de la question s'adresse à
madame la ministre déléguée auprès du
mythe de la santé 2,6 millions de
téléchargements pour l'application stop
qu'ovide seulement en 493 personnes
alertées
le président de la république l'a dit
lui même je ne prendrai pas ce chiffre
pour dire que c'est un échec mais ça n'a
pas marché
monsieur le premier ministre en lançant
tout senti qu vide se félicitait du
succès de l'application numérique dans
d'autres pays
et pourtant de l'australie au danemark
en passant par singapour et la malaisie
aucun des outils numériques développées
n'a fait véritablement ses preuves
malgré des taux de téléchargement
parfois très élevés en ce jour
l'application allemande a été
téléchargée plus de 18 millions de fois
mais elle n'a permis de l'identifier que
5000 cas contacts en allemagne comme en
france l'utilisateur a le choix de
reporter ou non le résultat de son test
dans l'application pour qu elle alerte
les personnes contacts dans ce pays au
30 septembre seulement 9% des cas
positifs identifiés depuis le 23 juin
avait reporté le résultat de leurs tests
dans l'application
dans ces conditions l'association des
médecins du secteur public en allemagne
a estimé que cette solution ne joue
quasiment aucun rôle je vais plus loin
même si tout cela fonctionnait que se
passerait-il
après c'est le sujet on a appris hier
que le personnel de l'assurance-maladie
saturé ne pourrait même plus appeler les
cas contacts ni passé plus de dix
minutes avec les personnes contaminées
les dispositifs qui ont fait leur preuve
repose sur une approche humaine et
cibler des cas l'isolément l'application
des mesures de suivi étroit des patients
grâce à des équipes d'intervention
rapide sur le terrain apportant des
conseils et du matériel alors une
question madame la ministre pourquoi ne
pas vous appuyer davantage sur les
médecins traitants qui ont un lien
privilégié avec les patients et qui
déplore de ne
être au coeur du dispositif pourquoi par
exemple ne pas avoir généralisé
l'opération pilote mené à la salpêtrière
pendant le confinement par le professeur
piarroux qui repose sur son expérience
concrète de gestion des pandémies
merci gilles bourguignon ministre
délégué chargé de l'autonomie merci
monsieur le président madame la députée
du mal face à l'accélération de
l'épidémie
nous devons mobiliser tous les outils à
notre disposition casser les chaînes de
transmission de la coved est plus que
jamais indispensable dans ce contexte
l'application tous sentis qu'ovide lancé
par le gouvernement le 22 octobre que
vous avez bien sûr tous télécharger
faciliter l'information des personnes
qui ont été en contact avec une personne
testée positive au virus et accélère la
prise en charge en complément de
l'action des médecins dont vous parlez
et de l'assurance maladie
comme l'a rappelé le conseil
scientifique les nouvelles technologies
constitue un outil utile pour retracer
les chaînes de contamination c'est
pourquoi son usage est particulièrement
utile dans des lieux où la concentration
des personnes rend le respect de la
distanciation sociales difficiles comme
les transports par exemple ou dans
certaines activités professionnelles
tous antico vide est une mise à jour de
l'application stop qu'ovide enrichi par
l'accès à des informations factuelles
sanitaires sur l'épidémie ainsi que des
informations pratiques comme les centres
de dépistage ouvert où le formulaire de
déplacement dérogatoire dans les zones
concernées par le couvre-feu elle permet
aussi à l'utilisateur d'être alerté ou
d'alerter les autres en cas d'exposition
l'utilisateur peut agir directement pour
sa santé l'utilisation de l'application
est fondé sur le volontariat et chaque
utilisateur est libre de l'activer ou
non pour les plus l'application pourtant
sera utilisée plus vite les cas contacts
seront alertés plus nous aurons
collectivement un impact sur le
contrôler l'évolution de l'épidémie
permettez moi enfin de rappeler que
l'application a été développée sous
contrôle de la cnil afin de garantir la
protection des données personnelles des
utilisateurs
elle a été informée des choix techniques
opérées dans la conception de
l'application elle avait rendu un avis
favorable
elle estime par ailleurs
cette application est utile
sanitairement et proportionnée au regard
de l'épidémie je voulais vous dire aussi
que par cette mise à jour conforme 4,2
millions de français ont téléchargé
cette application à ce jour je vous
remercie de votre question merci à mes
mains madame la ministre
comme d'habitude vous êtes uniquement
dans la théorie moi je vous parlais de
la pratique des exemples étrangers du
fait que ça ne marchait pas y compris
dans le métro puisque ça marche avec le
bluetooth et qu'effectivement il ya un
énorme problème de dect s2 détecte à
sion 2 débute pour détecter pardon dans
le métro la parole est à monsieur
mansour kamardine merci monsieur le
président mais c'est le premier pas vers
le projet de différenciation des
territoires qui pourrait impacter
l'unité de la république
le gouvernement demande aux marais de
réfléchir sur ce que pourrait être en
2031 mayotte en 2031 je veux vous
répondre ici et maintenant devant la
représentation nationale pour vous dire
ce que nous voulons c'est n'est pas une
redéfinition de notre statut
départemental auquel nous sommes très
attachés car il nous donne pleinement
satisfaction
ce que nous voulons c'est la
sécurisation des frontières à mayotte ce
que nous voulons c'est la mobilisation
pourrait conduire vers pays d'origine
l'erreur des gens qui n'ont pas à être
là et qui terrorisent les populations
régulière à mayotte ce que nous voulons
c'est la mise en place d'un régime
juridique met un frein à l'accès à la
nationalité automatique au regroupement
familial automatique au droit d'asile
automatique
ce que nous voulons et se prémunissent
c'est l'égalité sociale l'accès à la
santé surtout à cette période de covin
real éducation nationale ce que nous
voulons c'est des freins culture de
développement dur pour nous permettre de
développer l'économie et l'emploi pour
construire toutes les mobilités locales
dont notre compatriote marais ont besoin
bref c'est que nous voulons c'est
l'égalité des chances en un mot ce que
nous voulons c'est un plan de rattrapage
économique et social pour le 101e
département français
pendant 40 ans l'état nous a dit ce qui
était bon pour les mort et messieurs le
premier ministre les temps est venu pour
que le gouvernement entende c'est que
nous voulons en prenne en compte nos
priorités merci chers collègues la
palette aval à marlène schiappa ministre
délégué chargé de la citoyenneté
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
mansour kamardine je voudrais vous
répondre sur votre interpellation au
sujet de la situation à mayotte vous
dire que la situation particulièrement
la situation sécuritaire que vous
évoquez à mayotte fait l'objet d'une
attention constante de l'ensemble dû
gouvernement et singulièrement du
ministère de l'intérieur et vous le
savez du ministère d outre mer les
violences qui ont été commises au cours
des derniers mois par certains groupes
et certaines bandes sont absolument
inacceptables et bien évidemment devant
vous monsieur le député le gouvernement
les condamne
je voudrais vous dire que nous avons mis
des moyens les services de police et de
gendarmerie ont été renforcées avec 421
effectifs supplémentaires depuis 2015 et
d'ailleurs je voudrais saluer leur
courage puisque le contexte pour eux est
particulièrement difficile vous le savez
depuis 2010 est des réorganisations ont
été menées pour pouvoir créer une
direction territoriale de la police
nationale qui s'adapte à la spécificité
du territoire de mayotte en lien et en
coordination avec les différents
services et notamment la création de
deux nouvelles brigades à conques voué à
d'emblée mis au côté gendarmerie
par ailleurs vous le savez plusieurs
centaines de jeunes sont mobilisés dans
des groupes de médiation citoyenne et le
préfet est en train de travailler sur la
mise en place de groupes de sécurité
intérieure par ailleurs sur l'autre
question vous évoquez monsieur le député
et sur l'immigration clandestine
je voudrais rappeler qu'elles
représentent environ 30% de la
population à mayotte avec les arrivées
quotidiennes notamment de coiffes en
provenance des comores et donc il ya
aussi pour nous une nécessité de
redonner des perspectives aux mahorais
dont la moitié est mineur et dont 80%
vivre sous le seuil de pauvreté
mais en ce qui concerne l'immigration
clandestine vous savez que les services
de l'état agisse et d'ailleurs je
voudrais partager avec vous le fait que
dans le cadre de l'opération chic en
drap qui a été lancé en août
19 par nos prédécesseurs l'objectif des
ventes neuf mille interprétations a été
tenue et d'ailleurs la situation des
reconduites à la frontière à mayotte
représente environ 50% des reconduites
du territoire national dont vous voyez
monsieur le député nous sommes à votre
écoute nous sommes à l'écouté des
acteurs locaux et nous agissons entre
deux rencontres
la spécificité du territoire de mayotte
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre je gavarnie merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
merci mais je rêve que vous répondez
quand brad qui avec des chiffres qui
sont en déça des réalités d'une part
d'autre part vous ne répondez pas aux
questions liées à l'égalité sociale à
laquelle nous répondons ainsi déçu et
voilà et donc c'était pour vous dire que
nous souhaitons nous souhaitons vraiment
que le gouvernement se mette à démarrer
c'est qu'il n'est pas malheureusement le
cas aujourd'hui merci la parole est à
monsieur philippe michel roth bauer
merci monsieur le président ma ma
question s'adresse aux ministres
agriculture j'ai saisi au coeur de l'été
en septembre et est aussi en octobre à
propos des céréaliers du var de la
provence mais aussi de l'occitanie
cherche cher à notre premier ministre et
des départements de la drôme et de
l'ardèche
car ce territoire d'excellence reconnu
par l'europe bénéficie du mistral qui
assèche nos cultures et permet de
fournir en semences l'ensemble des
céréaliers de france avec des grains qui
sont dépourvus de certaines maladies que
l'on peut trouver là où il ya de
l'humidité nous fournissions absolument
tout tout le monde en france y compris
en betteraves et cette spécificité
territoriale nous permet aussi de
d'élever un blé dur de haute qualité
reconnue par l'europe et qui alimentent
les usines de pâtes alimentaires très
prisé de chacun d'entre nous et qui sont
situés dans la métropole marseillaise et
qui emploie des centaines de personnes
toutefois ce blé dur ces céréales sont
elles aussi menacées
menacé par la facilité facilité qu'ont
des cultivateurs d'offrir leurs terres
au lavandier qui plante qui récolte qui
distille et qui petit à petit prennent
l'essentiel de la surface exploitable
dès lors nous avons une réduction de
cette production de blé dur et de
céréales
dans nos territoires qui devient
préjudiciable au niveau des usines de
pâtes alimentaires dont je parlais de
l'agglomération marseillaise et qui
pourrait décider de se délocaliser si
notre culture continué à décroître
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me suis
adressé au ministre à plusieurs reprises
et que j'ai l'invité à venir à la
confluence du verdon et de la durance
terres de jean giono mais aussi très
cher à christophe castaner auquel nous
pensons aujourd'hui est de venir nous
rencontrer de venir nous rencontrer mais
je vous je vous invite à y venir
monsieur cordier aussi vous serez le
bienvenu et de venir soutenir nos
céréaliers de provence d'occitanie et
des départements de drôme et d'ardèche
merci merci la parole de monsieur
gabriel a tall secrétaire d'état auprès
du premier ministre porte parole du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
michel chris bauer je vous prie
d'excuser l'absence de geignards de
normandie qui a dû nous quitter en cours
de séance pour rejoindre le sénat où un
texte le concernant et d'examiner une
réunion va être remontée avec grand
intérêt par julien de normandie et avec
surtout toujours le même souci de
protéger notre agriculture et notre
souveraineté alimentaire je veux
indiquer que les équipes du ministère de
l'agriculteur culture ont d'ailleurs
déjà tenu une réunion avec les
représentants de la filière fin
septembre c'était à la demande de vos
collègues
anne laurence pétel et monica michel
cette réunion a permis de faire le point
sur les difficultés rencontrées par
cette filière du sud de la france tant
du point de vue de la production de blé
dur dans les zones traditionnelles que
des usines de transformation
alors qu'est ce que nous pouvons faire à
court terme pour aider cette filière
dont nous mesurons évidemment toute
l'importance le plan de relance est une
opportunité à saisir
je pense notamment aux moyens importants
que nous prévoyons au titre du plan de
restructuration de filières agricoles et
alimentaires au sein duquel une aide à
la filière blé dur aurait pleinement
vocation à s'inscrire à moyen terme il
nous faudra réinterroger les outils de
la pac
évidemment vous le savez les aides
couplées au programme sectoriel les
mesures en vue
montayral au titre du premier ou du
deuxième pilier ces outils doivent être
utilisés et leurs cibles et leurs
critères d'utilisation doivent être
définies dans les prochains mois dans le
cadre du plan stratégique national bref
vous le voyez l'engagement du
gouvernement et complet sur ce sujet
pour défendre la filière blé dur celui
des services du ministère de
l'agriculture l'est tout autant
nous allons trouver une solution nous
allons nous mobiliser comme nous avons
commencé à le faire à travers les
réunions qui ont eu lieu et nous savons
que nous vous trouverons à nos côtés
pour cela merci monsieur le ministre la
séance des questions au gouvernement est
terminée la science deux suspendus